de juifs qui ont un petit litige
financier David emocher donc ils vont
aller voir le grand rabbin pour régler
le problème David il parlera pas il dit
voilà Monsieur le rabat on a un problème
avec Moshi voilà on veut savoir est-ce
que pour vous la couleur noire est-ce
que c'est considéré dans la Torah dans
le est-ce que c'est considéré comme une
couleur et dit mes enfants moi quand on
pose une question je dois aller me
retirer dans mon bureau je vais étudier
et je vous donnerai la réponse quoi il
va dans son bureau il étudie il étudie
il revient il dit bon oui d'après Nora
oui
d'après les enseignements qu'on a eu la
couleur noire
c'est comment parler une couleur
le blanc maintenant le blanc est-ce que
le blanc c'est une couleur il dit oui
bah pareil je vais aller étudier
il va il études
et tout il revient et il dit bon mes
enfants voilà
pareil réponse c'est que d'après un
cadeau je m'en fous qui nous dit que oui
le blanc c'est une couleur comme le noir
les deux sont des couleurs et David il
se retourne vers moche et tu vois que je
t'ai vendu une télé en couleur